bonsoir un événement dominent
l'actualité de ce jeudi
humiliés les morts pour terroriser les
vivants s'attaquer à la mémoire et aux
souvenirs et tuer les gens une deuxième
fois
c'est véritablement le choc ce soit en
france après la profanation de tombes
juives au cimetière de carpentras un
acte sans précédent on a brisé des
pierres ont la même
exhumer des corps acte barbare qui n'a
pas été revendiqué sur place les
policiers n'ont pratiquement trouvé
aucune trace et pas d'inscription les
réactions sont unanimes pour condamner
beaucoup évoquent un climat actuel qui
incite à de tels actes de haine nous
allons y revenir d'abord l'effet
commentaires jean marc pitte images de
nos équipes de reportage c'est en venant
se recueillir sur les tombes de leurs
morts que des habitants de carpentras
ont découvert l'horreur dans le
cimetière israélite de cette commune
le cadavre d'un homme récemment inhumé
avait été déterré et empalé sur un pied
de parasol une trentaine d'autres ton
monte également été profanées membres
brisés socle soulevée mais apparemment
aucune inscription antisémite
les parents des occupants de ce
cimetière sont aussitôt accouru pour
constater le sinistre dans leur bouche
la consternation c'est plus facile cet
internement convoi
c'est spectaculaire disant certaines
tombes sont plus la rigolade
ce sont des gens ce sont des débiles
mentaux s'attaquait démons je vais vous
dire une chose il faut être vraiment bas
sur terre et ces gens là j'aime bien les
choses
finn vraiment y avait une justice il
envahit d'horreur il devrait repasser
les morts pierre joxe le ministre de
l'intérieur en visite à nîmes a tenu à
réagir
avant même de se rendre sur place nos
pensions que des abominations assiste
tout simplement d abomination qui sont
des crimes contre l'humanité ne pouvait
pas se produire dans notre pays
hélas elles viennent de se produire à
l'égard de mort à l'égard d' dépouille
mortelle pas seulement à l'égard de
tombeaux de tels actes de profanation
barbares criminel aux yeux de ce que
l'humanité a de plus spécifique qui est
le respect de la personne humaine
demande une condamnation solennelle et
indignés qui s'exprimera j'en suis sûr à
travers la france dans les heures qui
viennent
dans la communauté juive de carpentras
l'une des plus anciennes de france on ne
souffre guère de l'antisémitisme
on n'y a d'autant plus de mal à
comprendre cet acte ce soir il n'a
toujours pas été revendiqué